she's back sneaky Hillary Clinton up to
her old tricks again and fueling 20-24
speculation after taking this shot at
Joe Biden's age and health listen
well I mean it's a concern for anyone
um and we've had presidents who've
Fallen before who are a lot younger and
people didn't go into you know heart
palpitations
um but he his age is an issue and people
have every right to consider it the
crooked ones driving the knife in
Biden's back during one of his most
vulnerable moments new poll numbers
showed the big guys in some serious
trouble less than a third of Americans
approve of his handling of the economy
guns and immigration
and Hillary is not exactly giving a
glowing review of his presidency
I am you know of the camp that I think
you know he's determined to run he has a
good record that three years ago people
would not have predicted would have
gotten done uh he doesn't get the credit
yet that he deserves for what is
happening out in the country I obviously
hope he stays you know very you know
focused and able to uh compete in the
election because I think he I think he
can be re-elected
if Hillary's not sealing buttons
nomination she's certainly stealing his
talking points
if Trump wins
which I do not believe will happen let
me just quickly say that if in some
scenario that were to happen
um it would be the end of democracy
United States the the list of potential
uh disastrous outcomes is longer than I
have time to go over with you but
it's why we can't permit it to happen
why any sensible person who looks at
that former president and says oh let's
do this again
um
needs an intervention
so explain the emotion behind that
because she's obviously jealous of Joe
Biden she's still hurt
maybe that Obama I don't know what's
going on she violated one of life's
rules that I taught you the other all
right what did she do she floated her
own balloon yep you cannot float your
own balloon but nobody will float it for
her anymore
so she has to float it herself which is
why it should immediately be shot down
over the Atlantic she has this tone of I
say this with regret
she doesn't say she knows exactly what
she's doing she's just basically
skewering him and she's saying all of
the things that they all talk of you
know they all talk about this that's how
the Democrats are talking amongst
themselves like but probably with more
coarse language there was a focus group
that just had was reported on in the
Washington Post where they talked to
people who had voted for Trump and then
Biden and one of the women in the
article said she was under the
impression because Joe Biden said it
that he was going to be a transaction
I'm sorry a transitional president
and she said and I believed that I
believed that he was going to get us
from one generation to the next and that
Trump wouldn't be president if we got
Biden in there they didn't think Biden
was going to run for a second term and
then for Hillary to say that what she's
going to be the one that everybody turns
to in the Democratic party like if
they're tired of Joe Biden right are
they not tired of her and I do think
that it's pretty hard to imagine that
she can say with a straight face that
she doesn't believe Trump can win
how did that go in 2016. and that in
2016 she said it would be the end of
democracy and America has proved
resilient obviously thrived in some ways
struggling in way other ways today and
she's just unbelievable I can't believe
that they still invite her to give talks
like that oh she's probably getting paid
Dana you think you got paid for that I
don't know I don't go anywhere without
getting paid
she she could have obviously said you
know he's done a great job and I hope he
gets reelected and that's it right oh
but that's not who she is Hillary
Clinton is the epitome she is the
essence of a woman who will step on
anyone right over anyone do what she's
got to do to get the front of the line
and I'm going to limit it to that okay
but what I will tell you is that one
week after the Durham report one week
where they come out and they tell us
this whole Russian collusion The hoax
was Hillary's idea and she told Joe
Biden and she told Barack Obama that she
was going to do it because the email
Scandal was too hot and she had to get
the prosecutors off her back one week
later she's running for president okay
you know age is an issue a baloney she's
75 he's 80. it's not age Hillary it's
confidence and the truth is that you
know since 63 percent of Americans can't
agree on anything today but what they
can agree on is the fact that Joe Biden
is not mentally sharp enough to be the
president and yet these Democrats they
come out and say I just hope he stays
focused which is translation the guy is
so unfocused his wife has to hold his
hand they have to remind him who's
standing there with him look how many
times does a woman have to lose running
for president that stops her from
running again she is the essence of what
we do not need in this country and you
know what Dana there's no question there
were metrics When Donald Trump was
president that no president had ever met
I mean there were things that happened
the highest number of African Americans
employed Asians women the economy you
know the animal spirits all that stuff
was great but she's going to come back
and say you know what it's the end of
democracy if Donald Trump wins so I'd
rather have a zombie Joe out there who
can't even talk about this country I
mean she just yeah Geraldo she
introduced the
idea that he might not even be able to
compete in the election well I think the
underlying tone was Will Joe Biden be
competent to finish four years why not
because of the Next Generation it's not
because of RFK Jr or Gavin Newsom it's
about Kamala Harris it's about
the demographic reality that the
possibility exists a very strong
possibility that Biden will not be able
to finish his his four years uh on you
know and be 86 years old so I think that
was the real message that Hillary was
sending that uh you know you really you
sure about this you sure about Kamala
because that's the she's really the
figure that haunts the Democrats more
than anything probably haunts Hillary
because she was supposed to be the first
female president
and then it will be Kamala or will it
Jesse because I postulate that what
Hillary Clinton is doing is what some
say Tim Scott Nikki Haley are doing on
the Republican side she's running for
vice president she knows she does not
have the party's Goodwill she also knows
there's a really great shot that Joe
Biden says he's not running against the
Almighty we all are who among us is
going to live forever I don't think
anyone at this table and neither is our
dear 46th president but Hillary Clinton
knows that women live longer than men
she's still got some good will and
certainly a lot of name recognition
within the party and it looks horrible
if someone like Gavin Newsom elbows
Kamala Harris out of the way but if a
woman who was once the standard bearer
of the party the Trailblazer the glass
ceiling breaker if she pushes Kamala out
of the way then she will mathematically
naturally probably be our first female
president oh I like it well if anybody
at this table is going to live forever
it's going to be Geraldo thank you Jesse
can I have whatever it is you're taking
Geraldo well you can I will not share my
way
first time you said that I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now